let's talk about the economy to start
with should we today as was being
pointed out the bank of england uh
saying that we're going to be in
recession before the end of the year and
that's going to last until 2024.
people watching at home and i'm guessing
some people here as well facing months
and months of hardship you've been their
chancellor for the last two years why on
earth should they trust you with the
keys of number 10
in fact because they've seen me as
chancellor over the last couple of years
and i think actually okay probably the
first time people really saw me was that
first press conference
when there was an enormous amount of
anxiety in the country about what was
going to happen to people's jobs their
livelihoods their businesses
and they didn't really know who i was
i'd just been a maid chancellor a couple
of weeks before
but i stepped up at that moment to act
boldly and radically to design things
that had never been done before in this
country like furlough that ended up
protecting over 10 million jobs saved
over a million businesses help families
get through what are two very difficult
years and for our economy to
emerge at the end of that in far more
resilient shape than anyone had
anticipated at the beginning and when i
go around the country people know that
that's what i did for them they're
grateful for it and that's what i want
to do as prime minister because right
now we face similarly large economic
challenges and it's particularly because
of their experience that i'm well placed
to deal with nothing you can do about
recession there is there or is there
of course there is of course back to
david david's question
that the number one thing we have to do
is not make the situation worse what is
causing the recession right as you heard
from the bank of england today and i
think liz said something before which
i'm just going to correct it's not the
tax burden that is causing the recession
that's simply wrong what's causing the
recession is inflation right that's the
root of the problems we have not just
here but in america and elsewhere so the
way we're going to get through this
first and foremost is gripping inflation
now we will and i always have stood by
people as you've seen me over the last
couple of years so i will help people
get through the autumn in the winter as
i've done before and then we will make
the right reforms to help grow the
economy in the long term and i i don't
think the corporate taxes propose with
more money to help people of course i
would do you know how much we'll have to
see the size of the problem but look
people can see 13.3 percent inflation is
what's predicted that yeah that's the
size of the problem and i don't want
that to be worse
and i don't want it to last longer so
what i'm not going to do is embark on a
borrowing spree worth tens of billions
of pounds put that on the country's
credit card ask our kids and our
grandkids to pick up the tab because
that's not right it's not responsible
and it's certainly not conservative but
you're promising tax cuts without
knowing where inflation will be
i'm the one that's not standing here
sitting here now uh promising tens of
billions of pounds of unfunded tax cuts
what you've actually said is no tax cuts
until inflation gets under control what
amounts to under control
when it's on a clearly downward
trajectory and we're we have good line
of sight that is returning back to
target right okay right but that doesn't
but that's why we need to be really
careful about policies that will make
that worse right and look you know if
that took the first question uh it was
you know i'm behind in this race i'm
just a bit confused so you're saying
these income tax cuts might not happen
you're talking about my longer term yes
of course i am yeah my longer term plan
i'm confident we can deliver it yes
right and that was the reason i
published that longer term plan and that
longer term plan for those watching was
to over time reduce income tax rates in
this country because i believe
really strongly in rewarding hard work
hard work is a value that i think is
really important i think most
conservatives share that view that hard
work is something that should be
rewarded the the best way to do that
through the tax system is to reduce the
rate of income tax and i wanted to give
people a sense of the direction of where
i wanted to take the country and the
economy and i want to build an economy
where we cut the rates of income tax
over time and we're going to do that not
by asking our kids to pick up the bill
we're going to do it by being
disciplined on public spending
you're very comfortable we know exactly
what you think what we don't probably
know about is foreign affairs as much um
so let me ask you about energy and food
bills and how that relates to foreign
affairs potentially um how high
do you think that energy and food bills
will have to go before we
reassess our support for ukraine
i i don't i don't think that's how we're
going to look at it actually because we
can make an enormous difference
over between now and actually next
winter in reducing our dependence on
russian energy so in the short term of
course we're going to step in and i want
to step in and help people more i
announced enormous support as chancellor
as prime minister i'll go further
because the situation is deteriorated
but what i'm looking to is by next
winter that we've got through this and
there's lots of things we can do to help
us do that so i give a couple of
examples right so so one thing we can do
is improve our energy storage because
actually we can import lots of gas in
the middle of the year takes time no no
we actually we can do that relatively
quickly improved energy storage during
the middle of the year but the other
thing we can do is energy efficiency now
many of you here many people watching
are living in homes where we can help
improve the insulation loft insulation
cavity wall insulation smart temperature
controls those are relatively small
scale interventions that don't take very
long or cost a fortune and government
has got money but if we turbo charge
that program we can not only reduce our
demand for energy which improves our
energy security we can also save people
up to 300 pounds on their bills now
that's the type of thing that we should
continue to support ukraine as long as
we lag our loft is that what you're
saying we need to be lagging our loft
anyway for climate change reasons right
because it's good to reduce our
long-term demand on energy right but
what we do want to do is make sure we
help people with their bills and that's
a good practical example of something we
can do on the conflict in ukraine boris
johnson has um
really thrown himself into the cause i
think everybody might agree with that
he's regarded as a hero apparently in
ukraine that's what he tells us he
brandishes his missile launches we've
seen that are you really
tough enough to stand up
to vladimir putin well just think for a
moment how are we currently standing
this is your hell yeah moment yeah so
how are we standing up to vladimir putin
right how are we actually doing it we're
doing two things right we're sending
arms
and money to ukraine which as we talked
about earlier i found from elsewhere in
government spending so that we could
free up that money to send to president
zielenski but what's the other way we're
weakening russia we're doing it through
economic sanctions right we're not
sending our troops into russia right
it's not diplomatic measures that are
making a difference it's economic what
are we doing we're targeting his
companies their access to global capital
markets his gold trading his central
bank reserves that's how we're
economically turning the screw on russia
who do you think put all those things
together
i did with all my finance minister
colleagues around the world working with
a treasury secretary in america working
with european finance ministers we
designed an international package of
economic sanctions that would sends a
very strong message that we will not
stand for his aggression it's the most
stringent set of economic sanctions the
world has ever seen and it is making a
difference and as prime minister i will
go further because there's more things
we can do so yes i'm tough enough and
i'm already delivering the measures that
are actually causing him the most
trouble
thank you
[Applause]
ben wallace um as we i mentioned before
said that you had to be overruled on
defense spending pretty patel the home
secretary reportedly said that you
objected to the rwanda plan during a
written discussion between the
departments brandon lewis the northern
ireland secretary former northern
ireland secretary has accused you of
putting up huge resistance on efforts to
override the northern ireland protocol
it looks as though there's a recurring
theme there doesn't that you say one
thing in private and then you say
something else for
voter consumption so should we believe
them
or should we believe you look when it
comes to the rwanda plan
i do believe in the rwanda policy but do
i ask tough questions when cabinet
ministers come to me and say oh look
we'd like to do this new thing yeah
because my job is to make sure that
yours and everyone else watching and
everyone in this audience's money is
spent properly that's part of my job i
wouldn't be doing my job properly if
every time some cabinet minister came to
me and said oh please can i have x
billion pounds to do this new thing i
don't say well hang on let me just check
this actually is going to work is it
worth our spending taxpayers money
spending 120 million pounds um on
sending 200 people to rwanda is good
value for money yeah well it's the pilot
right so the pilot bit is expensive so
you're asking now exactly the questions
i was asking so if pretty patel or
anyone else is going to say oh now i
expressed some doubts about it it was
doubts about how we're going to make the
policy work i believe in the policy but
it's not good enough in government to
just announce things that's not good
enough to put out a press release it's
what you need to do is deliver things
and i think what people saw from me
during the pandemic as chancellor that i
could deliver things i actually
delivered policies that worked and made
a difference which by the way were done
in record time and were radical and i
will bring that same sense of grip and
urgency and competence to all these
other challenges whether it's the rwanda
policy whether it's the nhs backlogs
okay let's talk about climate you
brought it up we're trying to whiz
through these topics as best we can
because obviously some of these people
have not got their ballot papers yet
some have and what you're telling them
both here in the studio and at home this
evening could make the difference as to
whether or not you are the next prime
minister of this country so let's talk
about the climate should we one issue
that affects not just our finances but
of course our future
is um your green credentials can i test
them
sure here we go
new coal mines
yes or no
there's they're local decisions but i
don't think we should be
importing coal from other places if we
have it at home okay what about fracking
where where has the support of local
communities i'm in favor of it okay but
we have seen some big issues with
fracking haven't we particularly in my
part of the world in the northwest of
england where we've seen at least three
earthquakes that apparently uh have been
caused by fracking yeah but we also as i
said most importantly it has to be done
with the support of local communities
but we do also have a study from i think
i think three different royal societies
i think of geologists and engineers and
i can't remember the third group but
it's online somewhere all of whom said
that they believe fracking is safe and
the seismic activity is not out of the
ordinary they're all the scientists who
have came to that conclusion not me but
as i said i'm supportive of it where we
can bring the local community along with
us because if we can get it to work it's
good for our long-term energy would you
raise flight taxes would i raise flight
taxes no why not well well i for because
as chancellor i already made a change to
taxation uh yes it was actually because
green though airline
i did two things one is i i reversed a
european rule that forced us to charge
people twice when they flew inside of
the united kingdom on air air passing
duty i didn't think that was right and
after we left the eu we could say we're
not going to do that anymore if you fly
around the uk because we believe in the
united kingdom it should only be taxed
once but at the same time i created a
new band
for the
longest tall flights the most polluting
flights we created a brand new band with
a higher level of tax so actually it was
balanced right so for the people who are
flying the farthest with the more
emissions they were going to pay more
for people flying within the united
kingdom we took an advantage of brexit
let me ask you about onshore wind yes or
no because i'm a bit confused on this
one offshore and i'm sure and forgive me
yes or no no okay you've changed your
mind no i haven't i just last night i
was asked a question i didn't fully
understand it and i misspoke but my
position on that is the same as it's
been okay how are we going to get to net
zero by 2050 with innovation
yeah and the type of future economy that
i want to create is one where this and
we talked about it in the answer to the
visas question from someone
if if we have an economy where this is
the best place in the world for people
to create invent discover new things we
will get there and we will get there in
a way that lowers people's bills now
that my business background my
experience means i know how to build
that type of economy and this we've got
to rush through this like well it's
important on net zero yeah there's an
enormous
if you don't mind quick fire questions
here we go do you personally support the
24-week limit on abortion uh as a
personal thing yes
i mean these these are these are
personal decisions they're not
government decisions
i don't think there's any need to change
the i believe in a woman's right to
choose i don't think there's any reason
to change the laws that we have why have
you abstained on every major vote on
abortion uh probably because i've not
been in parliament on the day
you didn't think it was important enough
to be there because as chancellor i'm
often traveling
2015 apparently were you chancellor in
2015. uh no but i mean these are these
are not free i mean i completely agree
with our current system of abortion i
don't think it should be changed so if
the vote i mean so that's my general
view that's always been like you just
haven't been you should have them in
there when the votes have been taking
place would you fist bump uh the saudi
leader mohammed bin salman as joe biden
did
i'm probably not a fist bumping type of
person i think probably
just shake his hands then i mean
yes i will shake his hand i generally i
think you do have to engage with people
around the world i i don't think
they're a country that we have a
relationship with
uh in a video here it comes from 2001
you said you didn't have any
working-class friends have you made any
working-class friends since you left
university yeah i mean i i was i think i
was a student when i said that we all
say silly things when when we're younger
i mean at the same time i was as you
know i was working in my mom's shop i
was out and about cycling around running
around delivering medicines to people or
people from all walks of life but you
know obviously i was a kid and i said
something silly so you do have
working-class friends now yeah i mean i
don't go around asking them what they're
there
to find themselves
[Applause]
i think we've moved beyond that as a
country actually i reassure you yeah i
think people are less interested in
where you've come from people are
interested in where you're going that's
the kind of country i want to build
right
thank you yeah
let me ask you the same question that is
trust about being prime minister being
the most invasive exposed period in any
politician's life anything you want to
tell us about
no i mean look i've had i've had a
relatively high profile job for two
years and i think people have seen me in
action and
they've seen hey what i can do they've
seen and much of my personal life has
also been talked about earlier this year
and that was an experience that i
took uh you know that i learned from and
and dealt with so yes i'm used to the
scrutiny another simple question have
you ever benefited financially from the
use of tax havens no
a venture capital firm you co-founded
tailman partners was registered in the
cayman islands
um so just to clarify i i personally
benefited absolutely never ever
benefited and have paid absolutely full
normal taxes wherever i've lived did you
set up that business no okay so you know
you weren't a co-founder in 2000 and not
the bit in the cayman islands you're
referring to i have nothing to do with
okay i mean i happen to work with a
company that has multiple offices all
around the all around the world but
that's not my responsibility it was not
running the company so you weren't in
any way paid by that offshore company no
connections when i was living in america
i paid all my taxes in america and when
i've lived in the uk i've paid all my
taxes in the uk as completely as anyone
else okay the reason i'm asking is that
as you know as all our audience know
you've had to clarify your wife's
non-dom status you held permanent
residency in the united states while you
were setting the taxes of british voters
which is what a green card means
you're building a swimming pool at your
constituency home while the public pool
in richmond is facing closure after a
400 energy hike
this has all led to a perception problem
for you people feel that you can't walk
a mile in their shoes because you're
walking in your prada shoes what would
you say to them
you know so
you know over the past couple of weeks
right i've been out and about across the
country talking talk to members talking
to members of the public and
as i was saying lots of people have
come to talk to me about that press
conference and furlough and what
difference it made to their lives do you
know i
i was wearing the same suit in that
press conference the same shoes as i'm
wearing now right i'm the same person
how much were they worth yeah
very slick i'm exactly the same person
right i'm the same person that stood
there and made sure that we helped the
country through a very difficult time
and that's what i'll do as prime
minister and i think the british people
judge people by their character and by
their actions not by their bank account
that certainly seems to be the case as
far as the audience is concerned here
but there's plenty of people who are
watching at home who would disagree with
that perception is reality and they
think that you're too rich to be prime
minister yeah well the reality is one of
the last things i did as chancellor was
announce significant help for people
with their energy bills this ultimate
winter to the question we had at the
front
from david i think it was right you know
that was david's question was about
helping the most vulnerable right people
who really needed help that's what i did
because look we're all going to have a
difficult time and inflation makes
everyone poorer and that's why i'm so
concerned about policies that will make
it worse and last longer and that's not
right but when we do need to help people
this autumn and winter our focus should
be on the people who most need our help
and actually you know when liz is
sitting here saying she's going to scrap
the nhs levy do you know who that
benefits that benefits the top 15
of earners right that's what that policy
does it's not going to help the people
that david was asking about with the
cost of living this winter right the
policies i announced as chancellor are
targeted on those people because they
are the people that need our help right
it's going to be really tough
it's going to be really tough for lots
of people and much as i want to support
them to work hard and do those things
right it's going to be just impossible
for some people and we need to help them
and that's what i did you can't do all
of that on your own um penny mordent has
backed ms trust ben wallace says back
mistrust nadim zahawi has
has backed uh liz trust sanji javid your
old boss has backed ms truss why are so
many people supporting her rather than
you right but but kay goes back to the
question right at the beginning
every stage of the parliamentary process
i had the broadest and biggest number of
support most closely with you and
they've decided that they prefer her
hang on the most mps in parliament and
all mps worked together in lots of
different guys around the cabinet table
with you day in and day out and they
said you know what actually top two
gonna happen penny more than are not in
the cabinet okay um but
every single
round of the parliamentary press was it
being your capital
ahead of everyone else and since it
finished more and more people have come
and joined the team so i'm actually i'm
really humbled by that and i'm delighted
and actually as we're answering a
question that support is drawn really
widely from across the parliamentary
party and and i'm not going to get into
who's going to have this job and that
job i've got a contest that i want to
try and win i want to be out and about
talking to all of you about my ideas for
the future but i will build a team that
reflects all the talent and traditions
of our party as i said you saw a lot of
that on display in this leadership
contest and as we talked about before
we're all one team we're all one family
we're going to come together after this
we're going to serve the british people
and then we're going to take it to
kirsten and win the next election
because that's the real prize
final thought when you go you know when
you look at yourself in the mirror at
night just before you go to bed and you
think all these people that are sat
around the cabinet table with me and now
they don't want to work with me they
think that the other candidates better
plenty of people sat around the cabinet
table also support me
right dominic robb the deputy prime
minister is out there right now talking
about it and lots of others but i also
as i said now
actually just him right
i think we only just have one person
right yeah much as we love you and we
love sky i think they're very tolerant
just one person giving up their evening
to come and talk to you later but look
you know i've been you know i've been
really hard to take that actually
i think i think he's the perfect place
to end it
thank you very much
thank you very much
very nice